I gotta hug this man.
I love this game so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey Marvelites!
Ryan Penagos, a.k.a.
Agent M, here outside the
Square Enix press conference
at E3 2019, where we
just revealed "Marvel's
Avengers" to the world.
Very exciting.
So exciting, in fact, that I
had to grab a couple of fans
and see what they thought.
Let's check it out.
I'm here with Bruno.
Amy.
Megan.
All right, I'm here
with my man Dave.
Dave, "Marvel's Avengers."
We saw the trailer.
We saw the reveal.
How are you feeling?
I can't put it
into words, man.
"Avengers" popped
on that screen.
You saw San Francisco.
You saw the Quinjet fly in.
I just-- I had a religious
experience, Ryan.
Captain America dies?
What?
And who was the person
narrating the entire thing?
You know what, after
watching the teaser
for about three years 100
times, this was so satisfying!
Man, I was stoked.
I mean, did you guys really
kill Captain America?
I'm really eager to see what's
happening with Steve Rogers.
We were already calling the
characters, like "I got Cap!
I got Cap," you know?
Everyone's just really
excited for the game,
and it caught me off guard.
Like, the gameplay
looked really cool.
Like, everyone looks like they
play completely differently.
When they
mentioned that it was
gonna be a four-player
online co-op,
we were like, "Yo, it's time.
It's time."
Count us in.
And you got great voice actors.
When we saw the voice
actors there, I was like,
we've seen them
all over the place.
We're in.
I'm gonna say it.
Game of the year.
Right now, I'm calling it.
Marvel, Square,
Crystal, thank you.
You're the champion.
No one else is gonna top you.
This is what I want.
If I could have it
tomorrow, I would love you,
but May can't come fast enough.
As you can see,
people are hyped.
And so am I. It's a
big E3 2019 for Marvel.
Stay tuned for so much more.
I'm Ryan, and this is
Marvel, your universe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]